news daily from science mission
regulation of skeletal muscle stem cells
that are indispensable for maintenance
and regeneration of adults skeletal
muscles is not known authors in nature
communications show that inactivation of
a protein called arginine
methyltransferase or PRM t5 prevents
expansion of stem cells abolish 'as long
term stem cell maintenance and abrogates
adult skeletal muscle regeneration but
not embryonic skeletal muscle
development they are empty five acts
mainly by silencing cell cycle inhibitor
p21 next in humans staph aureus
infection produced superantigens and
obeys individuals have a high risk of
frequent exposure to superantigens in
vivo superantigens induce pro in
inflammatory cytokines in adipocytes
which may contribute to the development
of systemic inflammation by producing
chemoattractants adipocytes can further
recruit immune cells to Oedipus tissue
once recruited these immune cells can
also be stimulated by superantigens to
produce additional pro-inflammatory
signals superantigens induced liver
damage which leads to a reduction in the
endotoxin clearance function of the
liver resulting in elevated circulating
endotoxin levels together with the
proinflammatory signals from the
recruited immune cells endotoxins in
circulation can further enhance and
maintain ongoing chronic inflammation t
sh t 1 induced lipolysis in adipocytes
free fatty acids can be taken up by
skeletal muscle and subsequently
converted to intramuscular lipids which
are strongly associated with the
development of insulin resistance for
more news visitors at www science
mission calm or science mission face the
page thanks for watching